ciao a tutti ragazzi e per questo video
sono fa vj oggi siamo su wired è chiuso
detto come cazzo si dice sta my wife
perfetta quindi ragazzi siamo su 4 feb
oltre a maltratta prof maltratta la
mamma ma tratta la nonna maltrattare
andiamo su qualche deficit che mancava
all'appello state scherzando per la
colonna sonora ragazzi a perfetto ai
ragazzi siano su melfi fuga una colonna
sonora che bellissima donna ma che figo
estero ma controllo c'è già ciao zio
tuttavia questa entra tranquilla fai
come se fossi a casa tua è zio tra ha
detto ma i flirt o bambino gioca alla
playstation alle 3 di notte con la play
uno tra l'altro mentre un ladro e in
casa con la torcia primo la torcia in
una torcia mischia rambo su le maniche
proprio è la madonna che cazzo era gara
ma col wrestling praticamente ragazzi
bambini sono i lottatori più potenti del
mondo è la madonna che cartella c'è una
torcia e non è una spada laser sei
tranquillo zio polese ascolta fratello
non so se ti conviene macchia del
pavimento e poi la mamma vedere ai
sporcato tour poi pensa male pensa che
le mestruazioni è rimasto lì a per bene
morale della favola se siete dei ladri
volete entrarmi in casa io ho una
bottiglia ho fatto tanto con una torcia
non immaginate cosa posso fare con una
bottiglia il sembra quello fatto meglio
in assoluto di tutti wac per ora
cliccare sulla porta che cosa cia la
porta di strahm scott addio seguì un
attimo vieni bravo bravo bravo x factor
non aspetta di entrare dentro perfetto
ok non trova dietro scommetto quello che
volete se fa mi chiama accoglie anche se
fermate
ora vado pazzo se avesse rubato ladro in
casa avrebbe fatto meno casino di quanto
ne hai fatto tu però che va mi sembra
anche abbastanza contento rotoli come si
gode la giornata
6 comma lo zio è stata una sorpresa
quanto bella va bene importa in questo è
entra in modo diverso ogni volta però a
volte fa i balletti sexy
[Musica]
abbiamo tutti con piacere visto che sai
fare le piroette ma bravo e cos'è posso
dargli fuoco cosa ci fai con una tanica
di benzina cioè camino chiude la peggior
sentisse pisciotto sotto ma lo sai che
la pipì prende fuoco zio lo sapevi anche
il culo a nova zio il culo a fuoco e un
tocco di classe c'è mi devi ringraziare
che succede ragazzi festa di compleanno
proprio a non farlo non farlo sapevo mi
chiama amico mio ma stai calmo poverino
ha fatto una pausa prima di urlare
bellissimo comunque ragazzi sta
diventando alquanto strano tre morti su
10 sono curioso di vedere che cazzo
il cassetto c'è una morte per il
cassetto ragazzi non so che cosa
cos'è la madonna cosa trovati soldi
soldi amico mio e basilico
come sei un bambino come come come puoi
aver la forza fisica per far sei un
cazzo di bambino non è possibile sei un
madonna ma john cena ti fa una pippa tre
braccia ma no è un ragazzi intorno 2015
lo voglio adottare come si adotta un
ragazzo che fa delle capacità di fare il
ninja che tali quali a quelle di mia
nonna lo becco in un nanosecondo
meraviglioso una coperta
c'è chi deve uccidere con il bello che
si alza anche scazzato quando tipo
piccole cose cobra i lamenti più belli
della storia ragazzi che io non vorrei
mila posti
fiero è morto e la prima volta in un
james che non muore il tizio che picchio
la prima guarda zio cia del buon whisky
ti va di sette nostro ecco così che io
offro whisky agli amici ragazzo mio e
sangue quello che se questo è più sangue
invece questo chiamasi sgambetto al
contrario spaccato un giusto un
ginocchio è ancora vivo
guarirà dissanguato sul pavimento lega
comunque ragazzi andiamo avanti che ci
mancano queste tre e poi di scegliere
ragazzi siete voi tra il castello
racchetta e cassetta ora scegliete
castello tutti castello avete letto per
tutti i castello spero abbiate tutti
castello perché se non c'è un dell'età
no ma va bene così castello ragazzi
vediamo chi cazzo sei fuori ti piace il
castello del regalo quella che vale
tanto e io te lo do allora guarda anche
le mani che mi tiro super non sporcarmi
cos'è una cassaforte ma veramente
ecco media certo per cui la scorta zio e
non è che si può come ti permetti di
spingere nona lo fa lui fermalo ma è un
cefalo sto amando troppo in alto
servizio ci faceva il fondo è caduto
bene prof scusa ai ragazzi cosa cazzo ci
faceva il phon ha staccato in sala
spiegatemi questa cosa vi prego ciò dei
dubbi bene il castello l'avete detto
ragazzi adesso passiamo la prossima
cassetta o racchetta cassetta va bene
avete tutti cassetta grazie mille news
la cassetta io non ce l'ho
ho mancato beccato un gatto in compenso
inutile chiarini zio perché c'è altra
roba che ci si può un coltello che
caracas i giorni del cazzo ma vuoi che
io faccia ma come faceva dai amico mio
ma decidi che ci deve fare un po di un
po uno un po l'altro perché si va beh io
io mia bravo bravo
il gioco del secolo cazzo i ragazzi ne
manca una scegliete racchetta
orecchietta avete detto tutti bottiglia
di racchetta che l'ultima noi su dieci
ragazzi non mi deludere con la racchetta
zio che l'ha lasciata per ultimo perché
ok in poche parole la racchetta non
serviva un cazzo di niente ma ok ma
neanche sporcato il vestito lurido
bastardo adesso chi lo dice a mia madre
che li pulisce cosa ti trascini cosa ti
trascina ecco è morto ma perché ci avevo
il cacciavite per terra poi ancora ecco
il cazzo bene ecco il cazzotto
ovviamente è morto mancava quello mi
sembra ovvio che anche se ancora ciò io
non so come ho fatto a non vedere il boe
che fai
se picchiato da so
è un killer cosa l'ho staccato un
orecchio come che cazzo sei un vampiro e
alla fine ho cliccato sui pesi ma ho
fatto presente tutto io
tranne i pesi alla fine ma ok tanto
sporco di cna che mi pulisco c'è gioco
di ettari di videogiochi lui è un idolo
unito la non so se sei capito qualche
the thief abbiamo concluso qui i ragazzi
bellissimo no seriamente è stata la cosa
più bella della mia vita
credo di non poter mai giocare più a un
videogame che mi dia le stesse
soddisfazioni di questo gesto bambino e
la vita guardate che il che sguardo
d'achille la donna le medaglie tele2 più
tele lancio spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi cosa senza servizio è piaciuta
lasciato momento mi piace è vero ogni mi
piace che mettete una medaglia in più a
sto ragazzo che se le merita come la
vita anche a passioni facebook che come
noi video trovato nella descrizione
sostenuti di scrittrici vigevano
prossimo vinto vedo ragazzi